there's also just
for me personally the stories of the
of somebody who truly struggled are
are the most powerful i know a bunch of
people don't necessarily agree because
you said perfection
perfection is kind of the antithesis of
struggle
but i look at somebody okay my own life
somebody i
i'm a fan oh i'm a fan of everybody i'm
a huge fan of yours i'm trying not to be
nervous here but
uh somebody i'm a fan of in the judo
world is travis stevens
he's a remarkable fellow by the way a
remarkable human being
insane in the best kinds of ways i think
i started judo i really started martial
arts
i have wrestled if you consider those
martial arts that's my
that's been in my blood i'm russian so
but beyond that
you know the the whole pajama thing we
wear the ghee
i started by watching travis in 2008
olympics
was that accidental did you know travis
prior to watching no no
i just tuned in now that's an unusual
choice it was just random you just tuned
in and you saw travis stevens
i tuned into the olympics and i was
wondering what judo is
and then i s i started watch
we're we're all proud of our countries
and so on so i started watching
he was i think the only american
in the olympics for judo uh
maybe the so this kayla harrison was
2012.
and ronda was there too so i watched
rhonda and travis
but obviously sort of i was i was
focused on somebody who also weighed the
same as i did so there's a kind of
uh i think 81 kilograms so there's a
connection
but also there's an intensity to him
like he would get
like angry at his own failures and he
would just refuse to quit it's that kind
of dan gable mentality
i just that that was inspiring to me
that he's the underdog
and the way people talk about him the
commentators
that it was an unlikely person to do
well right
and i they the fu attitude behind
that saying no i'm gonna still win gold
obviously he didn't do well
in 2008 but that was the
that was somehow inspiring and i just
remember
he pulled me in but then i started to
see this
sport i guess you can call it
of effortlessly
dominating your opponent and like
throwing
because i in to me wrestling was like a
grind
you kind of control you slowly just
break your opponent
the idea that you could with like a foot
sweep was fascinating to me that
just because of timing you can take
these like monsters
giant people like incredible athletes
and just smash them with
it it just doesn't there was no struggle
to it it was always like a look of
surprise judo
dominance in judo has a look like the
other person is like
what what just happened yes this is very
different from wrestling
it's built into the rule structure too
the whole idea of an epon of a
match being over in an instant and um
that creates a a thrilling spectator
sport
because you can as you say with ashley
wise or the foot sweeps
um you can take someone out
who's heavily favored and if you're not
judo is the most unforgiving of all the
grappling sports
you can if you have a lapse of
concentration for half a second
it's done it's over um if those guys get
a grip on each other
any one of them can throw the other the
the idea
you know uh when you see someone like
um namura who won three
olympic gold medals to to win across
three olympics
and that's an incredible achievement
given how many ways there are to lose in
the standing position in judo and how
unforgiving it is as a sport it shows an
incredible level of dominance
you